england and wales are at a covered
crossroads
but although cases are rising we should
be better prepared than in march
we have a contact tracing app only
it keeps on having problems first
hospital tests wouldn't register on the
app now we've found
another issue this notification telling
people they've been near someone with
covid19
the department of health and social care
told us this was a test alert
from google and apple the real one
looks like this and will show up in the
app
like this but already the test has
forced one person
into self-isolation i clicked on the
notification
and uh it disappeared just literally
went
and nothing in the app said anything to
do
with uh a notification saying
you know that someone had been near me
someone had been near a tested positive
and um ultimately i'm now self-isolating
if the notification disappears that's
actually a sign
it's a test when people who got it
called nhs111
they didn't seem to have heard what
would have thought
that when the app was released one of
the first things you would have done is
kind of conducted extensive training
with the one-on-one members of staff
who told them right if somebody calls
you if they receive this message they do
this
if they receive x message they do why
well yeah it is quite down in the
comments it seems like that's not
really occurred in this situation
products are never perfect when they're
launched and the app is constantly being
improved
but given that it's already been in the
republic of ireland and northern ireland
and scotland and germany in switzerland
and
trial for a month in london it is
strange that the communication on the
app
isn't as clear as this
there was a choice to be made i think
between putting out something very
simple and very clear
that gets it right the first time and
therefore builds a lot of trust and
confidence
or what the english app has gone for
which is putting in an awful lot of
different functionalities such as the qr
code login and so forth
the app is gaining users rapidly with 14
million
downloads although if people don't
understand its notifications
can it actually be effective we asked
apple and google for comment
but from them and on this question
we're still waiting for notification
roland mantle
sky news